Hello.
My name is Reto Meier, and
welcome to This Week in
Android Development, on Monday,
September 16, 2013.
Last week, the Android Design
in Action team focused their
laser-like attention
on the UX issues we
encounter most often.
And I was back for the next
chapter of my DevBytes series
on efficient data transfers.
This time, looking at ways
to batch and bundle your
transfers using sync adapters.
Our favorite intern was back
to teach us about ListView
Cell Insertion Animations.
And for mobile developers of a
slightly different stripe,
Todd Kerpelman offered an
introduction to using Google
Play game services on iOS.
This week, join Wolff and
Joanna as they talk you
through the development of NFC
Hunt, as featured this year at
Google I/O. And I'll be back
again for another efficient
data transfers DevByte, this
time looking at how to
eliminate polling and refresh
problems with
Google Cloud messaging.
We've also got another animation
DevByte, looking at
how to implement a
folding layout.
And a few designers based in
New York City join Nick and
Roman at the New York Android
Developers MeetUp on the 20th.
In other in-person action, this
year's season of DevFests
has officially kicked off.
So check the site for details of
Google Developer Group led
DevFests near you.
That's all for This Week
in Android Development.
Be sure to check out
this week's bytes.
I'm Reto Meier, and I thought
I found the connector, it's
just a reflector.